en el centro de Teherán las escolares
corean muerte a jamenei el líder supremo
de la República de Irán las comisarías
permanecen envueltas en llamas y un
anciano muestra su apoyo a los
manifestantes
Estas son las imágenes de Irán que se
difunden en las redes sociales mientras
continúan las manifestaciones en todo el
país cuatro semanas después de que
marcha a mínini muriera tras ser
detenida por la policía de la moral
iraní el presidente que acusa a las
fuerzas extranjeras de provocar esta
revuelta nacional emitió un comunicado
el enemigo pensó que podría seguir sus
deseos dentro de la universidad sin
saber que nuestros estudiantes y
profesores estaban despiertos y no
permitirían que los falsos sueños del
enemigo se hicieran realidad Este es el
mayor desafío al que se han enfrentado
los dirigentes clericales en años ya que
mujeres de todas las edades se
manifiestan desafiando al poder pero las
manifestaciones masivas se enfrentan a
la violencia de las fuerzas de seguridad
en mashup una joven yaz inconsciente
tras haber sido presuntamente tiroteada
aquí un conductor también ha recibido un
disparo mientras iba en su vehículo como
este hombre que cambió el lema la
policía al Servicio del pueblo por la
policía mata al pueblo o este cartel ya
no tenemos miedo Vamos a luchar